what do you feel about the the future of
moviemaking with these characters that
haven't gotten like further yet like
your prophet your Lady Deadpool these
characters that are also your babies
that are on the short term list well so
something like prophet is in great shape
we have Marc Guggenheim writing the
screenplay I when I there were a number
of writers vying for the job to write
the screenplay and I knew when I met
with Marc that he was the guy and uh
Studio 8 was really excited to fit in
his schedule he's very in demand and we
had a couple conversations and I'm like
wow Marc really gets it he's the right
guy I'm honored that he's even
interested he expressed that he was a
fan back in the day I've known mark for
about a decade I was a fan of his comic
books that he was writing prior to him
taking over the CW with the arrow show I
remember walking out of the bayfront
Hilton in San Diego maybe eight years
ago as the arrow cast was getting direct
ready to board because the cast was
staying there and the little back area
they were getting in the van to drive
over to go through Hall H and I shipped
marks and I'm like I'm really excited
for you congratulations and obviously
that really worked out for him he he got
he had a great very very I cannot tell
you how true and reflective of the comic
book what he's doing but he's bringing a
fresh Guggenheim kind of a couple new
little little twists in there that are
great um so that's on board if that
first draft is great I guess we'll find
a bubble to shoot it in video 8 is super
hot on it